you have a Russell on the album we
talked a bit off the air about the
Russell I just was in Vallejo at his
house which is [ __ ] crazy he had a
concert in his house insane now a lot of
people know where he lives yeah
interesting yeah but no but but in a
good way but like it was like really
inspiring to see like just what he's
built and like how he's like really it's
like a really like his dad's there
cooking his mom's there his sister's
helping out like it's like a real family
operation it's like just real dope like
obviously you know he's been doing his
thing for a couple of years but just
talk about the Russell obviously you
know you having him on that record is a
was a big look for him at the time you
know what I mean like it's a huge that
song's fire as [ __ ] again it's crazy
yeah yeah I mean like dude what he's
doing is like
um what I think a lot of people like
like forget what the what it what it's
really about you know what I'm saying
like music
is really supposed to like really like
bring people together yeah and like you
know what I'm saying it's like a
community yeah and like what he's doing
over there is like he's really building
that community and really having people
be a part of it and I think that's
that's what's like a lot of [ __ ] is like
music is just like missing that right
you know and I think he's like really
showing everyone like what what that
means and he's all doing it himself and
like we were just talking about like man
he if he's got 10 people
rocking with him he's he's gonna like
turn that into a hundred he's gonna turn
100 into a thousand yeah like he's just
he's got it you know what I'm saying
he's gonna he's gonna figure it out and
also like very reminiscent of like Bay
Area Independence independent Roots like
independent when I think of the bay when
I was growing up I think a [ __ ]
sell it CDs out of the trunk E40 like
yeah like he he's like that's he's he's
that in this area in this in this time
frame and it's just it's dope to see
it's the dope to see him continue to
grow and and the way and the way he's
just like bro he's like ripping beats
like every day yeah
not even like the bird like he's bro
he's got a schedule in his like office
that's like five he posts six things a
day and it's like this one's this it's
crazy it's like it's really like
militant how like put together and
organized his operation is man that's
that's that's the real Bay Area that's
that real you know what I'm saying
organizing and really really getting it
done and being independent and you know
like I love what he's doing and you know
what I'm saying I commend what he's
doing and I really hope he can reach all
the highs he wants to reach